so based on what we've seen so far give
me a team
that you think has done a good job of
taking care of its off-season business
and reaching its objectives
well i'm going to keep pounding the
table for the tampa buccaneers mike the
defending
super bowl champions have gotten it done
if you look back let's go back in
history mike
2002 they won the super bowl right they
were horrible the next year seven and
nine the next year and they didn't win
another postseason game until when until
this
year they were horrible that team fell
apart now their defensive pieces were a
little bit older and that's what carried
them and brad johnson was at quarterback
it's not like they had that franchise
quarterback
to take him back to the super bowl but
this team has been kept together
and i think they've done a great job and
they have a great chance
now to repeat with what they've done
this off season i
never thought they would be able to keep
all these guys
to to be able to franchise chris godwin
to extend tom brady theresa
lavonte david shaq barrett gronk ryan
suckup
they're close on getting sued back they
extended donovan smith today we even
talked about him he gets
two years and 31.8 million his contract
now runs through
2023 and it guess what it freed up 10
million in cap space for this year
they still need to address a couple
things you know they may or may not get
a b
and fournette back i think they're fine
even if they don't get those guys back
but they do need to address backup
quarterback and whether that's in the
draft or with one of these veterans or
however they do it they
do need to address that mike but they've
done a terrific job
this offseason with getting these guys
back and give them a second chance to
repeat
how dare you speak ill or at least imply
ill of blaine gavert the backup
quarterback for the tampa bay buccaneers
who
now has a super bowl ring or eventually
will have a super bowl ring take that
fran tarkinton dan marino and dan fouts
blaine gabbert got what you don't
have that's one of the things i just uh
it's just amazing to me how many guys
out there have super bowl rings and
there are so many great players who
deserve them so much more no offense to
blaine gabbard he knows
he knows we know we all know um i agree
with everything you said about the
buccaneers
they have called their shot they have
kept their guys it's down to leonard
fournette and antonio brown they have
systematically found ways to keep their
players creating cap space
going all in for a second straight year
you know last year
when they signed antonio brown during
the season
an executive with another team said to
me
i don't understand what the buccaneers
are doing they are
so short-sighted they are building
nothing they're going to regret this in
a few years well
they got a new super bowl trophy to help
them deal
with whatever disappointment they may
have when tom brady's gone
in 2024 or 2025 and they may end up with
two
so uh sometimes it's good to go all in
on a one-shot deal if you get a super
bowl and now they found a way to extend
that
to two years and they could get two in a
row by the time it's all said and done
washington could be the two-time
back-to-back champion of the nfc east
i like what they've done it's very quiet
it's very systematic bringing in a guy
like william jackson the third corner
curtis samuel receiver ryan fitzpatrick
at quarterback
under the radar team that just is going
about taking care of what it needs to do
quietly trusting that the team will
continue to grow
the development of chase young montez
sweat
some young players who have real
potential terry mcclure one of the best
receivers in the game
already antonio gibson was a great
running back last year
as a rookie in washington and i just i
like that they
they didn't rush into anything they
didn't overpay anyone
they're just they're just checking their
boxes taking their time checking their
boxes
get a player we need here get a player
we need there get a player we need there
and the next thing you know they're
better than they were
in 2020 when they went seven and nine
all things considered this is a team
that we can look at right now and say
they are better than the team that last
played in the wild card round of the
postseason
i'm right there with you mike they would
have been my number two pick in the nfc
with what they've done
they didn't find the franchise
quarterback that they wanted they tried
to get in on matthew stafford they
didn't get him so they have the bridge
quarterback right and we know what ron
rivera thinks of kyle allen and what he
thinks of tyler taylor heineke
after what he did in the postseason
against the box
but just all the moves they quietly made
i thought curtis samuel was one of the
best
bargains in free agency with what he can
do in the run game and as a receiver
william jackson as you said they
resigned dustin hopkins and by the way
they franchise tag
brandon sharif who's one of the best
guards in football so
this is a team i think again just what i
said when we're talking about dan snyder
i just think they're building mike i
think they're building towards something
special here they've got to find that
franchise quarterback maybe they do it
in the draft but i don't think they're
pressured to do it in the draft because
of what they have at quarterback
and ron rivera seems to like all three
of these guys right now
and i'm glad you mentioned brandon sherf
because
it had been bothering me i knew i was
missing a franchise tag guy for the
second time who has yet to do a long
term deal
dak prescott justin simmons leonard
williams
of the cowboys broncos giants
respectively all took
second tags turned them into long-term
deals sheriff hasn't done that yet
because
look if you don't if you don't do it the
guy's gonna be
unrestricted next year you're not gonna
tag him a third straight time because
for non-quarterbacks it's quarterback
money or
a 44 raise over your cap number in your
second year which is prohibitive
for any position including quarterback
but for other positions
it's just not going to work so they need
to get that worked out with sherf as
well that's more work they need to do
but we otherwise like what they have
done
so far give me another team in the nfc
shireen where
you like what they've managed to take
care of so far in the off season
well i like the rams and i like it for
one simple fact okay i'm
i'm not convinced and i know you guys
are
more than i am that that they upgraded a
whole lot at quarterback
i get it but they were convinced that
jared goff wasn't going to get it done
for them right so they moved on and they
were able
to find a team to take that contract and
start over again with matthew stafford
at the most
important position in the game so i like
that
that they weren't just gonna stand pat
and go hey this is the guy that got us
to the super bowl two years ago
let's just keep going with jared goff
they had realized
he's not going to take that next step
for us let's move on
they did that and and i thought that was
a really good move for them resigning
leonard floyd to me was was huge
now i'm glad they kept darius williams i
think he's important to them
we've talked a lot about giving him the
first round tag i don't think that was a
good idea i think they could have gotten
by with the second round tag
but they did it and they assured that
they were going to keep him nobody's
going to give up first round draft pick
for darius williams so he's going to be
on their roster
this year so i like some of the moves
this rams team has made
especially considering what they did
last year with the number one overall
defense they still have the best player
in football and aaron donald
and we feel like they've upgraded a
little bit
on the offensive side with the
quarterback and
and i respect their ability
to unload the jared goff contract in a
way that was not
nearly as conspicuous as it would
have been yeah it's accepted by some in
league circles that it was a one and a
three for matthew stafford
and a first-round pick to take goff's
deal and look the average fan
is not going to understand that maybe
even the average staying cronky
isn't going to understand that and i
really do think at some level
the folks who run that football
operation
les snead sean mcveigh kevin demoff to
some extent
they need they need to be sure that
stan kroenke is okay with some very bad
decisions they have made as it relates
to who should get paid and who shouldn't
get paid they dragged their feet with
aaron donald
they gave money to todd gurley and to
jared goff
way too early they traded for jalen
ramsey without getting a new contract on
the way through the door giving him
all the leverage in the eventual
negotiations on his second deal
they have made some bad business moves
there's no denying that and i'm not why
do you hate the rams i don't hate the
rams i love truth
and the truth is this team has somehow
managed to be highly functional on the
field
so functional on the field that we
haven't really noticed
the dysfunction when it comes to who
they pay and who they don't pay
and when they pay and when they
shouldn't pay and go ahead and pay
anyway
arizona cardinals are a team that i like
what they've done they're not content to
be
eight and eight or possibly worse this
year
possibly fourth place in the division if
the 49ers are less injured
if the seahawks are less dysfunctional
and if the rams
continue to upgrade the way that we
think they have
first you go get jj watt then you get
rodney hunson in the trade with the
raiders
you bring in aj green a move that
surprised a lot of people
i like what they're doing i like how
they're going about business kept marcus
golden let hassan redick walk away
there's a question as to whether or not
he was a flash in the pan last year he
obviously thinks he wasn't
i i just think that this is a team
that is at least trying and it didn't
feel like desperation
it it feels like a conscious
deliberate effort to address areas of of
need
and to try to improve the team so i got
no problem
with with that approach even though yeah
did they give j.j watt more than i think
they should have
yes is aj green a calculated risk
absolutely
but i like the fact that they know
they're in the toughest division in
football and they're not going to stand
pat with what they have
yeah i agree with you mike and they'd be
in my top four as well i think they've
had a really good offseason i think
jj watt and aj green will bring that
veteran presence to both sides of the
ball
i think that helps i probably would have
preferred larry fitzgerald over aj green
but
that's just me aj green can at least
provide leadership if nothing else he's
your third receiver maybe your fourth
receiver
on this team so yeah i like what they've
done i think they're going to be
competitive in that division this year
i'd be stunned if the cardinals don't
actually know that larry fitzgerald has
decided not to play for them this year
everyone's taking the high road
they wouldn't have signed aj green if
they thought he was coming back i really
do think he's waiting
to see whether or not he climbs on board
with the super bowl contender
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports